[Musique]
il fallait pas de savoir si on aura
encore un c'est quand nos vies nous
sommes en guerre qu'on veuille est en
guerre contre un ennemi qui est
déterminé qui veut détruire ce que nous
représentons ou a été l'action de ce
gouvernement depuis trois étés finul
soir rien d'acté fois aux côtés depuis
quatre nuits on fait beaucoup de jeunes
depuis quatre jours beaucoup de gestes
de communication je trouve d'abord que
les parents devraient rester hors de
l'école et [ __ ] la paix aux aux profs
comprenez il ya parfois des mélanges de
genres c'est à dire que les parents
doivent évidemment donné l' éducation à
leurs enfants
mais ce sont les professeurs qui sont
chargés de l'instruction ils sont pas
chargés se substituer aux parents
défaillants
pas plus que les parents n'ont à venir
dire comment il faut enseigner et cetera
la république décapité avec ce dessin de
riis le directeur de la rédaction
on y voit les têtes d'un pompier d'une
factrice d'un juge d'une infirmière et
du président emmanuel macron et puis
cette question à qui le tour ça m'a
toujours choqué d'entrain dans un
hypermarché est de voir qu avait en
arrivant en rayon de tels cuisines
communautaires et de tel autre à côté
voilà en tout cas moi c'est mon opinion
c'est comme ça que ça commence
communautarisme pas là je pense moi ça
ne me choque pas à moi quand je fais mes
courses je veux au rayon produits
bretons voyez pas ce que je suis breton
et je vais faire l'économie d'un v6
terroir voilà qu est choquant c'est
qu'on se retrouve là aujourd'hui le jour
d'un hommage national
un professeur qui a été assassiné à
commenter les turpitudes d'un ministre
de l'intérieur qui sont aurait dû
réfléchir à deux fois à ceux qui le à
ceux qui le disaient les questions
peuvent être posées mais le jour où la
question
des rayons de supermarchés sera
prioritaire pour le gouvernement c'est
que nous aurons réglé un certain nombre
d'autres questions auparavant et
notamment celles que nous avons évoquée
depuis le début de cette conférence de
presse bannissement du voile dans
l'espace public
regardez ce qu'il dit dans dans
l'express c'est l'ancien premier
ministre il faut bannir le voile de tout
l'espace public pas dans la rue mais
dans les établissements scolaires
universitaires lors des sorties
scolaires et même dans tous les
établissements recevant du public
je suis d'accord sur ce point je pense
que le voile est devenu un outil de
propagande est un outil de 2,2
provocation je pense que notamment là où
il y a je dirais dynamique républicaine
c'est à dire notamment dans
l'enseignement bien sûr que dans les
universités
il faut arrter des fois là là où la
république s'enseigne là où la
république se défend se construit il ya
un an emmanuel macron disait le port du
voile dans l'espace public n'est pas mon
affaire
oui c'est ce que je vous dis france
inter est une secte
oui une secte gauchistes qui discrimine
systématiquement et dans ses
commentaires
tous les éditorialistes tous ceux qui
s'expriment sont véritablement dans la
secte et puis les invités sont
discriminés de la même manière donc ça
si vous voulez les comics sont là pour
ça mauvais comique sans talent riz ya là
la politique globale de l'immigration
auquel il va aussi falloir s'attaquer
car si on assèche pas encore une fois le
terreau du communautarisme qui l
immigration massive
alors on assèche sera pas le terreau du
fondamentalisme islamiste lié le
communautarisme entre pas là dedans je
ne le ferai pas
vous entrez dans rien parce que ça fait
vraiment que vous boucher les oreilles
les yeux donc est prévu que quelque
chose a été accusé de tomber dans la
droitisation c'était aussi grotesque que
tu fais des erreurs dans la
communication comme beaucoup d'autres
j'ai dit à 13h de tf1 que le port du
masque en population générale n'avait
aucun sens pourquoi est ce que je le dis
parce qu'on l'avait dit parce que des
médecins me l'avait dit parce que
c'était la doctrine qui n'a changé que
bien après
et beaucoup de proches et parfois des
amis ont été emportés je crois qu'on a
sauvé beaucoup de vies et ce serait bien
qu'on se le dise un petit pas